so Michael we're meeting with you on
this current trip of yours in Los
Angeles and you were set to go back to
New York and your new york life and
auditions in a little bit but how long
have you been thinking about coming out
to LA for pilot season um it's been a
couple years it's uh it was I don't know
it's probably been about three years
three or four years that I've known I
wanted to come out for pilot season and
it's just this is the first year that I
was actually able to like set myself up
to actually come out here you know save
up enough money and you know have I
don't know yeah oh that's a huge you
know yeah that's good yeah the money is
a huge player but what else were you
doing in the background like putting out
feelers to people contacting your
manager lesson yeah once I decided that
like I was definitely going to come out
here um I contacted pretty much everyone
I knew out here be it actor friends who
were in the same boat that I know from
high school in college in New York and
then I also contacted any directors and
casting people that I know which isn't a
huge crop out here so I but I reached
out to everyone I knew and set up a
couple meetings that way come you know a
lot of actually a couple people were in
New York while I'm out here so it didn't
work out but yeah when you say
contacting them what's I'd love to hear
the nuts and bolts of what that is it
just high on Facebook is it was a no was
an email I mean I feel like Facebook is
too casual you know um I mean a lot of
my friends who were out here i just hit
up on Facebook and was like hey i'll be
on in LA but no any like true industry
contact that i wanted to try and set up
a meeting with i did through email yeah
like I reached out to marc webb was the
first person i emailed when i got out
here and unfortunately he was flying to
New York like two or three days after I
landed so we didn't get to meet up but
yeah so and then or what are you
bringing with you I mean head shots or
you don't
that anymore everything's just online so
yeah I mean you don't really need it but
I brought a box of head shots in a
couple printed out resumes you still
bring him to the audition and but now
like a good fifty sixty percent of the
time they don't want to take them
because they have it digitally but other
than that no I I'm it was more so like
getting my online stuff all set up I
riada today's were up on like actors
access and now casting those different
casting sites that they use and then I
like redid my website just that kind of
stuff all my promotional materials i
made sure we're up to date and stuff
before i came out okay are you doing
that yourself or you have someone that
you hire ya know i edit my real and do
my website I mean the website I I don't
know all the computer languages and
stuff it's one of the what do I have it
through now Go Daddy and they have like
a site builder it's like a drag-and-drop
kind of thing you can design your own
templates and stuff so yeah just use
that
you